Boeing CEO Dennis Muhlenberg defended
the safety systems of its 737 max Jets
his first comments to shareholders and
reporters since two deadly crashes
involving the best-selling plane those
crash has killed 346 people and led to
the worldwide grounding of the max Jets
growing number of potential
whistleblowers are raising safety
concerns Kris Van Cleave is in Chicago
where Boeing investors gathered to hear
from the CEO Chris everybody wanted to
hear what he had to say good morning to
you
well good morning Gail and I think a lot
of people were a bit frustrated by what
they heard we can tell you now that CBS
News has learned it's not just the FAA
that has heard from whistleblowers but
also the House Transportation Committee
has confirmed it has heard from quote
several confidential sources about the
737 max and it's approval process and
it's likely more people will come
forward especially after a somewhat
startling admission by Boeing late
yesterday there are some that feel you
have a real credibility issue when you
when Boeing has not come out and said
you know we didn't do this right yeah I
think those are very first hours after
CEO Dennis Muhlenberg took questions for
the first time since Boeing's second
deadly 737 max crash the company even
caught regulators by surprise admitting
the cockpit warning light that could
have alerted pilots to a crucial sensor
malfunction was supposed to be a
standard feature but was never activated
on many machs jets Muhlenberg promised
to fix the planes with a certified
software update implemented the 737 max
will be one of the safest airplanes ever
to fly in both deadly max crashes
investigators believe a faulty sensor
triggered M cast the Jets anti-stall
system which put the planes into a dive
but Muhlenberg refused to acknowledge
flaws in the Max's design at the young
caste system as originally designed did
meet our design and safety analysis
criteria and our certification criteria
you couldn't have possibly designed a
system that would activate 21 times
pushing the nose of the plane down to
the point of an unrecoverable dive there
are multiple contributing factors there
are factors that we can control in the
design and in this case that common link
related to the Mk
system and its activation we're gonna
break that link Boeing faces several
lawsuits including one on behalf of ten
Canadians killed in the Ethiopian crash
Paula Drogo lost his wife and three kids
I stay up all night crying thinking of
the horror that they must have endure
the focus of the software fix that
boeing has been working on now for
months is to fix the issues with em Cass
it could be in the hands of regulators
in the next week or two it's beginning
to look like sometime this summer the
max may resume flying passengers
whenever that happens CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg says he and other Boeing
executives will be on the first flights
Nora Chris you have some excellent
questions yesterday at that press
briefing great reporting thank you